questo in realtà in video horror però
soltanto voi sapete in realtà che cos'è
il vero horror di quello che state
vedendo però vabbè questa roba
fateci caso pronto realaudio di video
dovrebbe essere migliorato di bestia per
gli agenti ragazzo è venuto questo video
sono fa vj oggi siamo su volevo la intro
[ __ ] perché non mia seconda due ore dopo
magari silent descent che è un gioco
horror è tutto a posto
i sottotitoli che limitiamo perché all
inglese
scisciano bene non chiedetemi che cos'è
perché un gioco horror che uscito da
poco su steam piove
la partenza da dio sempre fatto bene tra
l'altro in the strike è strano tranne il
titolo che la beta cosa già horror che
l'ho pagato 6 euro
la gazette leggete la gazette alla
madoff cercando i caricamenti di gta
sono più veloci cioè non posso dirvelo
ancora ma mi aspetto gioco incredibile
dal caricamento dura così tanto mi ha
ferito sei messo un'ora e mezza per
caricare una porta al i problemi ai
permessi
potevo fare qua da vorrei bussare però
vabbè dai bussiamo
[Applauso]
e tutto a posto non fate come quando
ascoltate le lezioni di chimica capisce
un cazzo
modern and women del libro di pietro
questa scavalca stai calmo mentre le
cose c'è del buon vino creek le tenute
di johnny cricche ragazze della casa
comunque apprezzabile sembra quale di
paranormal activity ma io non ho capito
le porte si aprono con che tasso non si
è ancora non si aprono a prescindere o
salve ma questo è un anno non è un
bambino non è ragazzino avanti perché
non ha veramente senso finora abbiamo
nello scantinato per me o 6 euro l'ho
pagato questo gioco se euro per vedere
il caricamento per ora fantasia una
domanda che mi sorge spontanea ma i 6
euro che ho speso per betrayed petraia
vuol dire tradito
credo non lo so e non mi ricordo ma
credo voglia dire tradito non sono così
esperto in inglese da sapere queste cose
promesse e rotte hai rotto le promesse
oltre che le promesse ai rotta anche
l'altra cosa ma tanto di così che the
three questa non l'ho capita troppo noi
che posso capire tutto esce anche il
tiro di sopra simpatico disperato adesso
capisci mio stato d'animo quando scarico
giochi del genere
ma non sia proprio la porta ma è normale
che non sia aperta la porta
e successo scusate se cerca il suo
cappotto e qui lo trovai qua e ha preso
qua devo aprire questa porta non ci
tengo abitando prova boe ha smesso cerca
il 3 ha forse un inizio circa il 3
chieco sesto 3 a faccia del balcone mi
date un 3 per favore ci sta roba è una
leva e c'è un'altra leva mazza aveva qui
devo trovare le tre leve eccola qua
madonna ma sono scioccato come la morte
io rientrare qua dentro
sì basta a farmi cercare cose basta ho
fame vuoi andare a mangiare fammi finire
questo or sono pure ubriaco sbaglio a
sam bird e il sacco giorno
c'era un tizio lì dentro veramente
brutto e non si tratta di pietro tutto
dipende da te aver non capisco cosa
intendi ma ok sentite lucifero se mi
devi sputare fallo adesso cava carmi
sono cagato serenità però la mia anima
piange e anche il mio portafoglio dopo
aver comprato sta roba
credo che sia il bagno più bello che io
abbia mai visto in vita mia ma non
volevo dirti troppi complimenti
la mia anima piangeva spesso chiusa
io andrei avanti visto che non cessa non
c'è nulla oggi no no no no no no no no
tutti fermi tutti calmi fatemi fare del
buon vino più venderli
era talmente scontato che non pensavo
succedesse permesso vedo che le stanze
sono una più bella dell'altra proprio a
rifare il muro
no è una valuta la torcia subito quella
proprio di base con un coro come se
avessi trovato la madonna alla chitarra
10 run a suona pure allora sì che gli
vale 6 a questo gioco ci player sereni
nera irisbus palin la guidare english
man magari cantare e c real mi mette
allegria
mi mette allegria ma non in questo caso
lui ma prediligo bay satana ha
funzionato bene
e via di qua via via via via via via via
via grazie vederci la prossima quindi
adesso immagino che mi si apre la porta
a infatti se un elicottero
chi se n'è andato tra l'altro elemento
che mi sono preso in mezzo spavento pro
grazie della bottiglia rotta gentile è
sparito a la credenza tutta e che si è
portato via mobile controllano mobili
spariscono mobili succedono cose che i
mobili comunque cose che non mi
piacciono questa roba
gesù sei tu e sparito gesù non sei tu
che devono toccare fare dire ciao o se
aperta la porta dietro gentile damiani
ma piangerla mi arriva questa lei
scritta la scritta un po fuori dal muro
però si è sbagliato zio c'entra il muro
la prossima volta che scrivi armi anima
piange a me la sentivo che sta bene può
fregare a me nella tua anima frega tanto
e prega tanto fai tanta ve maria tante
tante belle cose è bene sempre più
simpatico questo gioco mi piace
sono contento aveva spesso i 6 euro
ovvero zio si contento che spesso i 6
euro
qua mare maru carmen accusa una tegola
di legno ma versi prego non sparisce
completamente gli effetti sonori quello
non era quello non era un chihuahua
ci scommetto quello che vuoi io ripeto
sempre se avete il ciclo usate gli
assorbenti lo ripeterò sempre in tutti
gli horror però sta roba qua
molto chiara quanto è beware attenzione
alla sirena la porta per l'inferno per
una sera sì l'ho capito la già detta
quindi stiamo entrando nell inferno
dovrebbe essere vestito bene per entra
qua dentro l'inferno satanassi sei sono
qui telo giu
[Musica]
ma sai le di lara gut è successo
silent hill 2.0 va bene ragazzi sono
entrato all'inferno le porte sono molto
più [ __ ] di quelle di prima quindi
all'inferno hanno delle belle porte non
hanno molto stile nell'illuminazione
delle stanze perché un giorno ancora le
torce [ __ ] arriveranno ragazzi ci
arriveranno massa il vero avevo vista mi
scusi lo sa che al culetto di fuori le
servono delle mutandine a posso entrare
qua molto bello abbiamo fatto la porta
si è chiusa bene a hai un puzzle
perfetto guarda non vedevo l'ora
ok ci ho messo 12 anni a fare sta roba
ho tagliato perché se noi vi riuscirebbe
di 60 gesù buon dio giusto c'è veramente
ho preso più parti che non so non
capisco che brutta roba moglie dalla
casa di prima pasta la mamma mia bastava
una cassaforte ma voi siete scemi ma che
sono lupin
[Musica]
vabbè vabbè era che ha concludo questa
prima parte e spero che i video vi sia
piaciuto spero che abbiate capito che
satana e nelle porte che non si aprono
ti conoscevo mi piace anche vari soci ha
guidato da descrizione questi i capelli
sono più horror del gioco stesso
però per questi non ho speso 6 euro mi
vengono gratis questa e una cosa triste
sono state si discute non ci vediamo al
prossimo video beh ragazzi
[Musica]